[موسيقى]
الآن كما تعلم ، أحب سوقًا
جيدًا وما يمكن أن يكون أفضل من السوق في
الرياض ،
أوه ، انظر إلى هذا ،
فهذا يعطي بريك-أ-براك معنى جديدًا
[تصفيق]
أوه ، هذا
هو العرض الذي أود أن أقوم به  المنزل
هو
أنهم رأوني قادمًا ، كنت مبتدئًا وطفلة ،
أنا أحب صوتي ،
ما هو الأمر مع كل أواني القهوة
والهواتف هذه ،
كل كشك به هاتف من
جيل مختلف
رائع ، الهواتف هي تخمين أي شخص
القهوة الآن أكثر إثارة للاهتمام
[موسيقى]
أتحدث عن ثقافة المقاهي في مدينة
تتميز بجنون القهوة
وتخصصها المتاح
ولديها صاحب مقهى
ليس تقليديًا
معروفًا باسم مغني الراب نابليون في
التسعينيات وجزء المشاغبين الأوائل
من مجموعة الخارجين عن القانون التي أسسها
توباك
شاكور تم توقيعي على سجلات صف الموت ،
كان لديهم سنوب دوج دكتور دري توباك
خارجين عن القانون ، لذلك كنا في
خضم هذا والأشخاص الذين
شاركوا داخل الاستوديو كانوا
أعضاء في عصابة كان موقفًا عنيفًا للغاية
ما
تغير تعرف  ما تغير هو
أنني سئمت من الطريقة التي كنت أعيش بها
حياتي كما تعلم بعد وفاة توباك ،
أردت شيئًا سيحقق
لي السلام وأنت تعرف الحياة السلمية ولكن
كيف وصلت إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
كنت أعيش  في المملكة العربية السعودية منذ 11 عامًا ، كانت
المرة الأولى لي في المملكة العربية السعودية عام 2002 ،
وأصبحت مسلمًا بعد شهرين بعد ثلاثة
أشهر ، ذهبت إلى الحج
اليوم ، إن مؤتة مسلم متدين والقهوة
قوية بقدر ما تحصل عليها
[موسيقى]
إنها جيدة  الأذواق قوية أحبها قوية ،
لذا فإن
مقهى MW في الرياض هو من صنعه
ثقافة القهوة والسعودية هي واحدة من
أسرع قطاعات القهوة المتخصصة نموًا
هنا فهو يطحن بدلاً من موسيقى
الراب وهو يعد اليوم بأنني سأكتسب أخيرًا
المهارة التي يطمح إليها جميع خبراء صناعة
القهوة.
ابتكار فن لاتيه
، يتم
قطع الضغط هنا وهذا واحد
هناك نبدأ
الآن ما
بدأنا الآن في دفع المنزل
[موسيقى]
لاتيه رقم اثنين
يخبرني شيء أنه سيكون هناك
الكثير منهم قبل أن ننتهي
حسنًا ،
إنه لا يتحرك إلى الأمام ،
دعني أرى أنك تقوم بواحد ، فلا توجد بارات في
المملكة العربية السعودية لا يزال الكحول ممنوعًا في الوقت الحالي ،
لذا انتشرت المقاهي ذات النمط الغربي
في كل مكان في
السنوات القليلة الماضية ،
إنه جميل ،
إنه اقتصاد اجتماعي بسيط
يخفف من القواعد و  أصبحت المقاهي
المكان المناسب للقاء ،
نعم ، نعم ، صحيح
عندما جئت إلى هنا لأول مرة ، لم يكن بإمكانك
الجلوس في الخارج وتناول فنجان من القهوة ، أنا
أستمتع بهذه الأشياء الآن أنت تعرف ما
أعنيه لذلك لديك الكثير من التغييرات
أعتقد أن هذا سيجعل المزيد من الناس يشعرون
وكأنني أستطيع ركوب دراجتي الآن في
الحي الذي أعيش فيه ، ويمكنني حرفيًا
تناول القهوة هنا وشرب شطيرة هنا ،
حسنًا
لاتيه
رقم ثلاثة
[موسيقى]
نعم ، أنت تفعل ذلك ، نعم هذا مثالي
مرة أخرى
مرة أخرى وهذا هو الأخير
الذي قطعه للتو ،
إنه جيد جدًا
[موسيقى]
لم أتمكن من تكرار تلك
الورقة الرائعة في الوطن ليست سيئة يا إخوانه ،
فقد
حصلنا على وظيفة من أجلك.
التقليديين
القهوة في العالم العربي هي السمة المميزة
للضيافة كما أنها تعويذة
التغيير